all our Science and Technology editor
Tom Clark is here with me now so Tom
what are the key features then from this
report do you know what for me and this
is somebody who's been covering this for
about 20 years it's really difficult to
put this one into context because yet
again we have another report these are
issued about every six or seven years
this is I think the third one that I've
covered each one more urgent than the
last each one urging us to take action
the consequences of don't do anything
become more and more severe with time I
think the significant thing about this
one I think the one that's really really
significant is this is possibly the last
time the world science is going to tell
us how dire the situation is
that we have a chance to act to avoid
that most dangerous level of global
warming of 1.5 degrees that's been
identified uh as the sort of the trigger
point in this report
because we are expected to hit that
sometime in the next decade in in the
2030s so we really are on our last
warning here
um and the reason that 1.5 degree is so
important is because as this report
tells us about three and a half billion
people living at threat from climate
catastrophe one form or another whether
it's sea level rise or droughts rainfall
extremes Etc so there's urgency to do
something about it for that reason but
1.5 degrees is all significant because
the long the warmer it gets the less we
have in the Earth Systems our forests
oceans to absorb the carbon dioxide
we're putting out there so the harder it
gets to go there so that's why this
rhetoric has reached this level but what
are we doing about it the analysis shows
that the commitments we've made so far
are way way way Beyond way way from
where we need to get to we need to urge
much harder and faster to get there the
positive spin on this which un Secretary
General was putting there too is that
this is could be seen as a tool kit for
diffusing about climate time bomb as he
put it
um because we know what we have to do
now we know what policies we need to
implement we just have to get on and do
it and even in countries like the UK
which has possibly the most ambitious
one of the most ambitious climate
cutting pledges of any major economy
we have we've certainly in on paper
we're doing what we need to do to limit
one point to get to 1.5 degrees of
warming however only about 30 or 40 of
the policies that we currently got in
place are actually properly thought
through are properly funded to actually
deliver out our pledge it's going to
take a lot more work yet to come
factoring the rest of the world we've
got a lot of work yet to do